il venait à peine d'être élu idriss deby
est décédé ce mardi midi des suites de
blessures reçues au front le président
tchadien avait été touché ce week-end
alors qu'il commandait son armée dans
des combats contre des rebelles au nord
du pays le maréchal du tchad président
de la république chef de l'état chef
suprême des armées
idriss deby itno vient de donner son
dernier souffle en défendant l'intégrité
territoriale sur le chat de bataille
c'est avec une profonde amertume que
nous annonçons au peuple tchadien
le décès ce mardi 20 avril 2021 du
maréchal du tchad idriss deby itno des
suites de ses blessures au front depuis
ce lundi l'inquiétude régnait dans le
pays
des chars avaient été positionnés dans
la capitale avant d'être retiré le porte
parole du gouvernement avait assuré sur
twitter qu'il n'existait aucune menace
particulière la mort d'idriss deby
intervient alors qu'il avait remporté
sans surprise l'élection présidentielle
tchadienne
ce lundi la commission électorale
nationale indépendante avait rendu
public les résultats provisoires du
scrutin selon cette instance
idriss déby candidat du mouvement
patriotique du salut aurait récolté plus
de 79% des voix
idriss deby itno 3 millions 660 3431 79
points 32% à la tête du pays depuis 30
ans idriss déby se diriger vers un
sixième mandat
il concourait face à neuf prétendants
dont trois avaient annoncé leur retrait
afin d'appeler au boycott du scrutin et
dénoncé la répression des marches
pacifiques organisées depuis plusieurs
mois cette mobilisation réclame est
également une alternance au pouvoir
malgré ce contexte le taux de
participation serait de 64%
toujours selon la commission électorale
un chiffre dont se félicitait le parti
du président défunt
nous fêtons une belle victoire au
premier tour mais nous avons aussi une
pensée très forte pour nos frères
nos camarades soldats de l'armée
tchadienne qui sont tombés sur le champ
d'honneur pour défendre la paix la
démocratie et la continuité des
institutions de l'état
en effet l'élection présidentielle avait
déjà été entaché par une attaque dans le
nord du pays lors d'une offensive le 11
avril dernier le fact front pour
l'alternance et la concorde au tchad
avait atteint le territoire tchadien
depuis la libye selon les autorités
un important dispositif avait permis de
les neutraliser
l'armée avait affirmé avoir tué 300
rebelles et perdu cinq militaires dans
les combats